depuis ce lundi 11 octobre la ville de
moscou a ouvert une vingtaine de centres
de test où la population peut donc se
faire tester gratuitement et ce en
quelques minutes comme par exemple ici
dans le célèbre centre commercial goom
en plein coeur de la capitale afin
d'enrayer la situation sanitaire duo
kobe 19 certains en russie évoque la
possibilité de mettre en place un
système d'amande afin de sanctionner les
non vaccinés mais le kremlin a fait
savoir qu'une telle mesure était
irréaliste et qu'il valait mieux user de
pédagogie afin d'inciter la population à
se faire vacciner
je pense que je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent cela comme une nécessité
le fait est que beaucoup de mes
camarades de classe et beaucoup de
membres de ma famille travaille comme
médecin dans les zones de qu'ovide rod
travaux relatifs à me caler des lots il
ya l'idée wyeth louviers et j'ai vu ces
gens et je crois qu'il est temps de les
sauver c'est tellement dur pour eux
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
il est nécessaire de se faire vacciner
c'est obligatoire si on parle de cofidis
9 je pense que la vaccination est
nécessaire
que l'effet du vaccin ne soit pas
entièrement connus chaque semaine nous
apprenons quelque chose de nouveau et ce
n'est pas toujours bon ni agréable
mais la vaccination est importante et
nécessaire cela peut être comparé à la
variole que l'humanité a vaincu
nous nous faisons tous à l'idée que la
vaccination est obligatoire plus il y
aura de gens qui se font vacciner vite
on mettra fin à cette situation
compliquée quoi qu'il en soit les
chiffres restent mauvais en russie sur
ces six derniers jours on dénombre plus
de 900 décès quotidiens avec la mise en
place de ce test gratuit et rapide les
autorités cherchent donc à limiter la
propagation du virus sans nuire à
l'économie